[Musik]
noch vor sonnenaufgang herrscht auf der
seychellen insel darß emsiges treiben
die forscherin ornella weideli will
früher zum nahegelegenen atoll hinaus
fahren um jungtiere aufzuspüren
relativ oft zu viel los ist
hayes und geflüchtet war einmal der
mitte das problem
ist das denn genau bedeute
und doch wird die fahrt ein wettlauf mit
der zeit
denn auf der insel poel am rande des
sind josef atolls zieht sich die flut
schon bald zurück
[Musik]
probleme schnitts die nato
details
die befürchtung bewahrheitet sich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und nun die sandbank versperrt uns den
weg wir versuchen es vielleicht besser
da drüben stress im paradies
einfach nichts bei uns leben absolviert
und war dort der lokale mitarbeiter
downs lucimara und ornella hoffen auf
junge zitronen und schwarz spitzen
refrain die sie werden mit einem chip
versehen dessen daten aufschluss über
deren lebensweise gibt
sie erspart den etat innerhalb von zehn
minuten
sie sind nicht auf dem auge verlieren
die lotterie haben es naturnahe machen
sollen wir mal ganz nach vorne gehen
ornella will die haie schützen denn sie
existieren seit 400 millionen jahren
der mensch hat sie in wenigen
jahrzehnten beinahe ausgerottet bis 100
millionen pro jahr und war vorher ja
oder sogar stört sie über die letzten
paar jahren
es ist wie für manager sie dank und
verdammt ist sagt rüdiger thust serbe
trotz problem ist die weiter ausbauen
kann
die große für große fische boot und gibt
es kein problem die fortpflanzung aber
theo zwanziger mit dem thema ähnlich
sieht das auch nur jahr einige pflanzen
tsch mythischer klar dass mit abstand
das macht dank ja gut dass ich so ein
stich kann sehr schmerzhaft sein aber
eigentlich sind stachelrochen friedliche
tiere die sich nur verteidigen wenn sie
sich bedroht fühlen
kein junghaie weit und breit
seit vier jahren sammelt alle auf den
seychellen daten aber heute hat sie
trinken
sony weiter ja wir haben die flut
verpasst lasst uns abbrechen
bis zum boot rüber gehen wir
[Musik]
würde ornella stachelrochen erforschen
wäre der heutige tag ein highlight
gewesen
[Musik]
wochen gibt es auch im indonesischen
tauchparadies reiter am bart mantarochen
umwelt lehrer jonas müller will den
kindern diese imposanten meeresbewohner
näher bringen
dieser mann posten soll sicherstellen
dass nicht zu viele touristen abtauchen
und die mantas vertreiben
ok
warum wurde dieser posten hier errichtet
weil es hier viele mantas gibt ja es
gibt viele mantas und damit die mantas
geschützt werden
ja darum wurde diese posten die
errichtet jetzt gibt es eine regel dass
nur maximal 20 taucher oder schnarchende
gleichzeitig im wasser sein dürfen
überhaupt nicht fahren nicht oder zu
gehen der horner
ich stehe mit ihnen das turnier nicht
gut mit den eta und bewertet wie wir
sind zum schluss dann die angst ist
verflogen
mantas sind bei touristen beliebt aber
ihr ansturm schlägt die tiere in die
flucht darum wurde der zugang limitiert
manta rochen und haie stehen in diesem
marinen park unter schutz
die touristen müssen für den eintritt
umgerechnet 70 franken bezahlen die dem
umweltschutz zugute kommen soll ein
manta rochen würde niemals in euch rhein
schwimmen
er stoppt immer rechtzeitig jagt die
nicht sondern wartet dann kommt er ganz
nah ran
jeder von euch krieg zu einem block und
einen stift
damit kann man unter wasser schreiben es
hat genug für alle
also keine sorge mit dem slate auf
glaubt dass sie den laga was verband das
aussehen also will ich bete vom antrieb
montage stroscher niemand da was man so
schlecht hat der mann eigentlich oder
weiblich hatte man unter verletzung dazu
geschrieben hat sich darauf achten was
machte mantra massa der sich rein egal
wer aus dem amt macht es und so hat sie
sagt ich hoffe dass man das war dann
auch sehr unglücklich
einfach nichts auf den seychellen hat
ornella weideli die hoffnung auf junge
noch nicht aufgegeben
man beschreibt den wohl erschreckt brian
daly ist der lokale wissenschaftliche
leute der schweizer stiftung save our
seas diese finanziert ohne dass
forschung mit gut gemacht was ist es ein
neuer zitronen neue figur erstaunliche
das jungtier wird gemessen die chips und
gewogen 55 punkt 2 1 aus gewachsener
zitronen über drei meter lang und bis zu
180 kilo schwer werden
die helikopter
wenn ornella einen hai ein zweites mal
fängt kann sie rückschlüsse auf dessen
lebensweise nahrung und bewegungsradius
ziehen
[Musik]
in recke amt freuen sich die kinder auf
die mantarochen gleichzeitig haben sie
aber auch respekt vor ihnen
[Musik]
doch erst einmal sichten sie viel
plastik aus dem unterricht von jonas
wissen sie dass die tiere ihn fressen
weil sie ihn für plankton halten und
daran eingehen können also sammeln die
kinder ihn reden
weiter unten ist das zuhause der manta
rochen schnell legen die kinder ihre
scheu ab
im wohl exotischsten klassenzimmer der
welt haben sie die gelegenheit die
wunderbaren tiere zu beobachten und die
fragen zu beantworten
[Musik]
nach dieser positiven erfahrung werden
sie die mantas künftig mit anderen augen
sehen
[Musik]
auf den seychellen sorgen delfine für
hochstimmung
mit dem tempo des bootes kennen sie
locker mithalten
[Musik]
das team von ornella weideli versucht
sein glück nun mit grünen
meeresschildkröten die reihe ist an ryan
dalli dem lokalen wissenschaftlichen
leiter der stiftung save our seeds
entwischt da ist noch eine direkt vor
dir siehst du sie spricht derweil das
vorhaben buch vom glück für grüne
mährische rotterdam sie koordiniert das
klingt einfach zu schnell ist aber
ziemlich schwierig sie ahnte da kommt
was
ja
schmeling
es hat viel schatten ich springe das mal
[Musik]
gerade hat sie eine grüne
meeresschildkröte
sie wurde noch nicht markiert wir
bringen sie jetzt zum ufer um sie zu
vermessen
vorsicht sie schlägt auslege sie kopf
verantwortlich hin
wir beobachten die brütenden tiere sie
sind am einfachsten weil sie an land
kommen über die jungen schildkröten
wissen wir weniger
die sind schwieriger zu können darum
fangen wir sie so sie sind ein wichtiger
teil der schildkröten population über
die wir nicht viel wissen
saint joseph atoll ist sehr wichtig für
die futtersuche und der schutz der tiere
schon vor vielen jahren wurde auf den
seychellen ein schutzprojekt für
meeresschildkröten eingerichtete ist das
datenblatt hier drin
ja da drin die grüne meeresschildkröte
stammt von der landschildkröte ab und
existiert seit 225 millionen jahren die
atemluft sie müssen nicht unter wasser
sein
ihnen ist auch über was er wohl benutzt
du dieses denn wir brauchen das kleinere
das hier ja
kannst du es sehen 19.04 9.9 4
wir markieren die schildkröten wenn wir
sie erneut fangen gibt uns das hinweise
über die anzahl tiere hoffentlich auch
bald an kaum je eine schildkröte zweimal
das bedeutet es gibt hier eine große
population
man schätzt dass ungefähr 2000 grüne
meeresschildkröten im saint joseph atoll
leben
auch für die erwachsenen tiere ist es
wichtig weil sie an den stränden ihre
eier ablegen
es gibt nicht viele orte wo wir
erwachsene listen der tiere und
gleichzeitig jungtiere haben die ihr
leben
es ist ein einzigartiger platz für grüne
meeresschildkröten im indischen ozean
ja
der schutz der tiere und der umwelt das
ist der kern von ornella weide ließ
arbeit und es ist auch zu ihrer
lebenshaltung geworden
sie glaubt lässt sich das wetter bis
dieses macht also zum beispiel flüge
sehr froh und klopfe jetzt wir bislang
gemacht dass man nicht ausser die frauen
hätten gefördert aber jedermann schreibe
ich glaube dass sie
[Musik]
am manta spot in writer amt genießen
jonas und die kinder den freiluft
unterricht die großen mantarochen haben
sie aus nächster nähe beobachtet und sie
haben gelernt
es sind freundlicher tiere
[Musik]
das ist natürlich genau und das sind wir
uns da und der kamera und dann plötzlich
löste hausnotruf und da wird das
natürlich da
der ausflug beinhaltet nachhaltiges
lernen und die freude am spielen in
einem
die auswertung zeigt bei den kids ist
einiges hängengeblieben
rebmann tasci aus der karibik das stimmt
sind alles riecht man das sind eher geht
er zwei bisher hat richtig erkannt und
david würde verletze das eine wort auf
oder vor dem antrag gestern ist und hat
auch schon schade wurden verletzt als
sie jedes kind
super gemacht dafür werden wir viele
mantarochen hast du gesehen hat jemand
mehr gesehen hat jemand weniger also
alle drei zumindest sagt das hier jetzt
keine mehr angst
ob das so ist das wird sich bald zeigen
wo wieder munter betrachtet aber dass er
so weitermacht dann sehen sie mehr und
mehr die schönheit und ich habe meine
schönheit verbissen wie kann ich meine
vielmehr bereite für bis zu machen und
die haben wir die mantas gefallen ja
glücklich
ja ich geschrieben
[Musik]
in grünland ist es ende märz die
landschaft in der nähe des polarkreises
ist prächtig anzusehen
sie ist geformt aus schnee und eis
das ist ganz nach dem geschmack des
zürcher multimedia journalisten robert
hanssen für sein hobby das eistauchen
legt er weite strecken zurück
aber bevor es soweit ist besucht er das
schlittenhunde rennen das nur einmal im
jahr stattfindet
es ist das ereignis für die
einheimischen und natürlich auch für die
touristen meinen hund wo er zuvor ist
wartet daheim
das lehne border terrier dann wird es
sicher aufbauen aber denkst darf man
keine hand mitnahm auf grünland das ist
strengstens verboten werden die türen
auf island wird das nicht erlauben im
transit das schönste aber im hochsommer
wird erledigt war hat er doch in
grönland bruch das arbeitstier und ja
ich habe noch nie gegen eine
touristenattraktion
dort hat einfach der der wettbewerber
unseren an raschen ausstieg des frieses
volksfest und die vorräte noch einmal
verloren
mit einem völlig dass man gerade jetzt
einen baustopp und jeans der rostock
[Musik]
die route führt über viele kilometer
entlang des gigantischen gefrorenen 4
für ein paar stunden vergessen die
einheimischen ihren entbehrungsreichen
alltag die meisten in ried leben von der
jagd von den geldspritzen dänemarks und
vom aufkommenden tourismus
das rennen ist für den multimedia
journalisten ein ideales sujet er
verfolgt es mit der drohne und wird
damit selbst zum ereignis
[Musik]
dann gehen die schlitten in den endspurt
[Applaus]
die hunde freuen sich auf frisches
robbenfleisch für sie eine delikatesse
[Applaus]
dem sieger winken ruhm und ehre und ein
drei meter langer schlitten oder aber
ein gewehr
er hat die qual der wahl
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für high forscherin ornella weideli geht
die zeit auf den seychellen dem ende
entgegen
bis im frühling will die 32 jährige ihre
doktorarbeit über junghaie im saint
joseph atoll beendet haben
was dann kommt ist noch offen
das so die hoffnung aber es gibt eine
sehr starke junge geboren war das wird
definitiv bis große rechnung machen ist
nicht möglich und persönliche freude und
nicht genau wüsste es nach das ist ganz
natürlich
ungewissheit beinhaltet auch freiheit
und die ist schneller wichtig auch im
privatleben
darum will sie diese zeit genießen
gemeinsam mit ihren freunden aus der
ganzen welt
[Musik]
glaube mir nicht im moment laufen was
man so hört zu tage
danke für planer und dahin und tat es
und da spare für das und nicht vergisst
mit dem dann haben wir auch eine
angepasste fahrweise einer weide ließ
geschichte beweist dass es möglich ist
seinen traum zu leben
denn eine forscherin aus einem land ohne
mehr hat den mut nach den sternen zu
greifen
[Musik]
nachdem hundeschlittenrennen hofft
robert hanssen dass ein lang gehegter
wunsch endlich wirklichkeit wird
denn ein solcher eisberg erwärmt das
herz eines jeden fall tauchers das eis
ist hart wie stahl und weiß die
verschiedensten blautöne auf flut und
ebbe lassen das wasser mit dem eis um
den berg anheben und senken allein das
ist ein spektakel seit fünf jahren reist
robert ans polarmeer seine frau renee
begleitet ihn so oft wie möglich
geduld ist er seine ganzen sieben sachen
eingepackt hat und ausgepackt hat und
die drohne wir verpackt hat und wieder
ausgepackt hat aber man wird reichlich
belohnt für die geduld mit solchen
reisen und solchen ordnern die man kommt
auf diese weise ist es wirklich schön
das ist schön unterwegs aber über wasser
natürlich nicht wenn die kammer zu einer
landschaft seiner gattin sohnes land und
alle züge land genießen und auch der
lifestyler wo man halt mit denen das eis
beim einstiegsloch ist denn anders als
beim letzten mal wo sich die
eisschichten entlang des ufers meter
dick übereinander gelegt hatten aber
diese eislandschaft ist vergänglich die
folgen des klimawandels werden immer
gravierender
diese veränderungen bekommt robert
expeditionsleiters wenn gust hautnah mit
und sieht schon dass die gletscher in
erschreckender geschwindigkeit
abschmelzen
diese die auswirkungen davon die die
lassen noch ein bisschen auf sich warten
aber wir sehen tatsächlich dass
tierarten hier zu finden sind plötzlich
also sprich wale zum beispiel portale
und pilotwale die wir hier früher gar
nicht gesichtet haben wir sind jetzt
normalität im sommer geworden das hat
sich ja innerhalb der zehn jahre also
sind wirklich nur zehn jahre wo ich das
hier erkenne hat es sich
und schon sehr sehr verändert wie immer
beim eistauchen ist die vorbereitung
wichtig denn im eisigen wasser muss
alles einwandfrei funktionieren das ist
mir eine noah zu kräftig die vorstellung
im kopf zu haben ist nicht so angenehm
und ein kleines loch aus dem morgen
wieder rauskommt das wäre nicht mein
ding
robert braucht eine dicke haut für die
minustemperaturen aber um sich einen
lebenstraum zu erfüllen nimmt er all das
in kauf
in eine dresdner spieler anderen weg
mutter der nation
[Musik]
reiter hat bedeutet frei übersetzt so
viel wie das reich der vier könige 1500
inseln gehören zu dieser gegend in
indonesien um dieses naturparadies zu
bewahren hat jonas zusammen mit
einheimischen eine ngo gegründet sie
heißt chaled said papa
[Musik]
heute hat der planer mit seinen schülern
etwas ganz besonderes vor er fährt mit
ihnen zu einem geheimnisumwitterten ort
[Musik]
das abenteuer beginnt schon bei der
anfahrt
[Musik]
basketball
wir sind da im wunderschönen ort in
rheinkamp möchte ich nicht verraten das
ist ein auto zum glück für die touristen
entdeckt worden ist und zudem unter
schirmen die schönheit der natur vor
über diesen abgelegenen ort wird
unheimliches gemunkelt es ist für sie
sich einfach einen ort wo sie mit oskar
verbraucher höhle wo sie auch betonte
nach wie vor noch und rauchen und da
haben aber keine augen meiner nüchtern
vor dem drachen also bereits an bord und
sie die drei bewohner das ist natürlich
vor 60 minuten da muss ich noch dran
glauben jonas will den kindern die ihre
insel nur selten verlassen die
drachenhöhle zeigen aber es gibt ein
problem laufen das gibt sich an ihrem
boot das große angst vor dem bösen
geister tor daraus dass er nach oben
schauen wir zurück wie das abläuft
seit generationen erzählt man sich
schauergeschichten ja die sind ganz
unterschiedlich ist kurz vor gericht
oder sofort spirits wo man etwas in
meinem buch marco kolb vom hocker und
dann sind ja geister wenn wir jetzt kann
wieder dübel zum beispiel was ist kühl
halten oder aber auch zu den spuk macht
jetzt habe der drachenhöhle natürlich
spezifisch an der thur und belohnt
[Musik]
ok hört zu wir gehen jetzt drauf aber
denkt daran ihr dürft nie zu nah am
abgrund gehen sonst fällt ihr hinunter
bleibt immer schön vom rand weg
[Musik]
im grünland taucht robert hanssen in
einer welt voller wunder ein
die temperatur beträgt -3 grad
das salz verhindert dass das meerwasser
gefriert der eisberg gleicht einer
gewaltigen skulptur mal sind die
konturen weich und rund dann wiederum
sind sie kantig und messerscharf
[Musik]
bis in 20 meter tiefe kann robert den
eisberg auskundschaften
in diesem nährstoffreichen wasser
gedeihen überraschend viele pflanzen die
braunen kelp blätter beherbergen
zahlreiche tiere wie den skorpion fisch
[Musik]
über wasser haben sich diese eiszapfen
gebildet weil die flut den wasserspiegel
anhebt sind sie nun für robert unter
wasser sichtbar
[Musik]
robert ist hochkonzentriert und vergesst
alles um sich herum
[Musik]
aber nach 75 minuten ist schluss
die kälte wird bedrohlich
[Musik]
robert hat schon über 500 tauchgänge
gemacht aber dieses mal war es
intensiver als alles was er bisher
erlebt hatte
das ist so schön und dann schloss der
sohn einer straftat nicht schön
so schön
vielleicht sind es solche überwältigende
momente die uns menschen demut lehren
und uns daran erinnern sorge zu tragen
zur einzigen erde die wir haben
[Musik]
umwelt lehrer jonas müller zeigt den
kindern von reiter amt eine unbekannte
welt
die sagenumwobene drachenhöhle mit dem
urlaub nicht an geister oder instant
bewohner dass sie das den bislang nicht
gehabt sich daher nach damit dass danach
bezeichnet und dass die dann eben auch
das macht das kloster drache nach unten
komm zu uns drauf kann er fliegen das
gewohnt hat und natürlich einem spucker
und portugal urlaub zurückkommt oktober
hat die sich diesen mist ich will eine
frau an deren ort
dass gott der vorsaison war hat mama
diana jacobi jonas respektiert die
sagenwelt der einheimischen
ich finde ich musste nicht vor ihrem
glauben auch gegen dann überhaupt nicht
ich finde das ist schön ich finde das
gehört zu ihnen
das hat sie gar nicht machen sturm in
frage zu stellen was die spezielle zum
nachdenken und zum teil noch geschichten
auch damit sei betroffen findet dann ein
neues marketing und küsse geschichte die
er beliebig also völlig okay diese
geschichte auch das macht das ganze dorf
interessant
mit meinem antritt oder etwas machen
kilometer vorbei man sich dem bestand
ist kann das ja eines tages in einer
entsprechenden position sind wo sie dann
vielleicht auch an die der richtige
hebel ziel verankert und das ist
eigentlich mit einer note
[Applaus]
[Musik]